hey everyone we're so excited to show
you heartland an all-new stand-alone
adventure in the division universe
the teams poured their heart into this
game and we can't wait to share it with
you
[Music]
welcome to silver creek
i'm keith evans creative director in
heartland at redstorm entertainment
we've been involved here at redstorm
with the division going back before the
first game launched our partnership with
massive entertainment made some games
that we love we're so excited to bring
something new to fans of the franchise
heartland's a free-to-play survival
action shooter set in the division
universe that features streamlined
survival gameplay and a beautiful new
world to explore
you play as a division agent given the
task of protecting silver creek a small
town in middle america from enemy
factions rogue agents and a deadly
contamination this game ties directly
into the timeline and introduces all new
characters and story lines to the
franchise heartland feels fresh and
distinct while still feeling at home
alongside the other amazing games in
this universe
we can't wait to have you join us in
silver creek
you